today we heard directly from the White
House for the first time since the
indictments of Russians for meddling
with our election the president's been
unleashing on its predecessor for
failing to prevent the sabotage Sara
Sanders echoed that earlier everybody
wants to blame this on the Trump
administration let's not forget that
this happened under the Obama
administration
he has been tougher on Russia in the
first year that Obama wasn't eight years
combined
she also addressed the media skepticism
about mr. Trump's admission of election
interference president has acknowledged
that multiple times before he
acknowledged during the transition he a
knowledge did it during a press
conference in Poland and he acknowledged
it for a third time at a press event in
Poland he has stated several times I
think one of the places where you guys
seem to get very confused and it seems
to happen regularly the president hasn't
said that Russia did meddle what he's
saying it is it didn't have an impact
and it certainly wasn't with help from
the Trump campaign Dana you brought up
the point yesterday that mr. Obama said
he didn't want to say anything publicly
about Russian interference in October or
November because he didn't want to be
seen as publicly creating a lot of drama
there for political reasons could he
have not done something in the shadows
yes and it is possible that they did and
that we don't know about it could be
something that they that they weren't
able to talk about maybe they would
declassify it now and we there's a range
of things I had ambassador Dan freed on
the daily briefing show yesterday and he
knew d.o great guy he is a great guy
worked in multiple administration's he
was a as a career civil servant became a
ambassador under the Obama
administration and working on Russia
Ukraine type issues and he said in 2014
they were hyper focused on Ukraine and
what to do there and started doing hi oh
there's confetti
my points I guess so they were hyper
focused on that activity in 2014 and
that they didn't realize the extent of
the operation that Russia was going to
try on the elections and the technology
was new and that he did say that there
could have been more that they could
have done back then I don't know exactly
what that might have been and there
could have been stuff that they did I
would say there's another reason for
President Trump to be mad at the
Russians not only did they attack the
country of which he is now the president
he's also even if he hadn't won that I
think that everybody should be mad as
Americans that this happened on our soil
but it's also because of what Putin's
goodnes actions here have worked to
undermine president Trump's presidency
and if I were President Trump I'd be mad
about that that's reason enough alone to
try to take action against Putin that is
an a lot of people have criticized mr.
Trump Greg for not being stronger when
it comes to sanctions although president
comes done a lot in terms of things that
have put Russia back on their heels more
so than what Obama did but on the
sanctions front people criticize him for
being soft there's a lot of hypocrisy to
go around and what we're gonna talk
about this about the protests being
sponsored by the anti protests being
sponsored in the be block what the
Russians have with the Russians
replicated on a small scale is what we
do to ourselves daily so all they did
was they came at they saw where they saw
our our team support politics I'm more
worried about bigger threats I'm worried
about our banking in our power grid and
and I think that's the stuff that's
really like that's the stuff that we
survive on we can live with we can live
with trolls even though they're a pain
in the neck we can live with trolls you
have me on the five but the bigger
problem here is that political party
leaders don't care about threats unless
they are a threat to their power right
it's not so much a threat to the United
States but you know how does it affect
our election and it and I think that's
what bugs me most about Democrats is
that they really aren't that ticked off
about the Russians until emotionally
they were affected by the loss of
Hillary Clinton that's what is driving
with their anger and that Trump won
that's why they're mad at the Russians
it's I don't I don't think it's about
the country
as much it is that they lost you and
your people no you wouldn't
yeah to your point would you have had
President Obama slap sanctions on the
Russians if Hillary had won he may not
have done it he made have just said you
know what it's not an issue we're not
going to make a thing out of it and
cause Hillary yeah if Hillary had won
and there wasn't all this crazy Russia
Trump collusion election interference
Russians were trying to collude with the
Clinton campaign oh no no no I'm saying
if Hillary had one do you think me I
don't even think Obama would have
slapped sanctions on the Russians well I
mean look here's the thing I think that
the it's really a concerted effort by
the Liberals by the Democrats to D
legitimized our president Trump's
election you know victory there really
isn't specific empirical evidence and
data to suggest that in fact it had an
impact on the outcome of the election we
certainly know there's no evidence to
suggest that there was tampering with
the election result the suggestion is
that these BOTS were operating and that
they were doing this you know a whole
thing to try to create chaos within the
American political system within the
election cycle and disrupting in that
way but there isn't any evidence to say
that it actually affected the outcome it
was out there and some of it was you
know it's out there but it wasn't in
such a way in large-scale force that I
think that it would have an ultimate
effect so now everyone's like whining
about it well guess what Russians are no
Russians Hillary lost
speaking of whining President Obama I
think was in October said this to mr.
Trump who was complaining about rigged
elections let's see it
there is no serious
person out there who would suggest
somehow that you could even you could
even rig America's elections there's no
evidence that that has happened in the
past or that there are instances in
which that will happen this time and so
I divided mr. Trump to stop whinin and
go try to make his case to get votes one
well this is to me then the most
impatient is that President Obama was
responding to then candidate Trump
saying he was worried about voter fraud
that people were gonna line up or the
big democratic party machines and cities
were going to somehow rigged the
election against him that's what the
President Obama was respond to now today
President Trump comes back uses that
quote that you just saw on the screen
and says that was about Russian meddling
can I respond because when when Trump
was talking about the election being
rigged I think he was talking about not
only the potential for he was talking
about fake Paul's he was talking about
combing letting Hillary the whole system
know he was talking specifically about
what he said was voter fraud and his
usual pointing to minorities and saying
oh this is what's gonna happen in the
big cities this is how they're going to
win this election they've got it rigged
and it's even suggesting that he
wouldn't honor the results of the
election because he was so concerned
about this kind of activity had nothing
to do at that point with the Russians
but here we are today and we're having a
discussion as if oh no President Trump
isn't distorting the news and isn't
misquoting President Obama we treat it
like it's serious he's the president so
we have to have this discussion but I
mean even over the weekend you just go
back and you stop and you think he's
attacking mcmaster his own national
security adviser for saying the Russians
definitely interfered in the election
you come forward and you say why isn't
he imposing sanctions he's not taking it
you say oh he's doing more than Obama
Obama not only throughout 35 diplomats
he closed down two Russian diplomatic
estates in the United States and imposed
sanctions and yet you were having this
touch as if he did more than a
he's not doing anything you actually did
that after the election and then ended
up dropping the sanctions that Bush had
put in place and allowed Russia to sell
anti-aircraft missiles to Iran and to
Greg's point though just to respond to
that the Democrats when Russia was
running wild under President Obama
didn't really care too much they didn't
seem very activated but the minute they
denigrate Hillary that's when the
Democrats really become cold warriors
well I think that's great point right it
was so that's why it's hard to take and
I also think like if we know that if it
had been the other way around and as I
was saying which I misunderstood what
you were saying earlier but that if
Hillary had won and the Republicans had
reason to believe that the Russians were
trying to help Hillary win and Trump
lose what would we be saying every day
so I I kind of I just think that they're
doing what they're going to do but at
the same time they've spent so much time
on Russia that now the Democrats if you
can see in the polling they're starting
to realize that they actually might be
on their heels when it comes to these
midterm elections because the tax reform
pieces move forward and there was a
quote from Jonathan Swan and Axios from
the Democratic retreat where Republican
democratic pollsters were saying that
the Republicans have the wrong message
but Democrats have no message and so
that actually I think while we're all
talking about Russia
the president has moved forward and the
Republicans have helped him move forward
on policy and the Democrats have ceded
that ground hoping that this would be
their saving grace I kind of said the
same thing that Swann said but so much
better yesterday and he has a nice
accent yes it was it goes back to what I
said about when you're an Olympic
athlete and all you train is for curling
and you don't have any backup job so
when the curling is over and the
Olympics are gone you didn't win
you can't go back because curling has no
transferable skills it's it's not gonna
help you get a job at FedEx so you're
still trying to make that one work a job
I think it's a good point that right now
that the Russian collusion story is
there curling and they've got to figure
out their back-up plan they'll probably
get one and it you know their back-up
plan will be will be that trumps awful
because I think that you all will you
have enough people that are so
vehemently opposed to him look there it
worked with
looking's you know with Obama oh yeah to
do is just say I don't like Obama and
that'll work and I think that'll
probably work for it for the Democrats
with Trump but they still don't have a
plan they're still curling I don't think
I don't think that's it I do agree that
they don't have a clear signal message
other than an anti-trump yeah but I do
think that what you're seeing is that
people I mean Dana was talking just a
moment ago about the tax plan becoming
more popular I think it's now over 50%
but let me just say if you were to have
a poll on ice cream and apple pie
wouldn't you expect like a tax cut for
everybody that your numbers would be in
the 80s or 90s not me I wholly crush
stomach cannot handle ice cream because
people are not realize so much of this
money is actually going to the rich into
the corporations and they don't like it
why is it that this president won't
impose the sanctions why won't he take
pro action proactive action in terms of
stopping the ongoing interference in our
politics by the Russians people answer
your question Kimberly got me because
guess what Kimberly would have sat here
and said look at Obama he is saying that
the Russians are interfering to benefit
Trump he's actually helping Hillary by
doing it that's what the Conservatives
would have said you know the votes
make it happen don't whine and cry about
it if you're not a good candidate you
know a lot of this stuff that
everybody's getting all ticked off about
is what would Trump's tweeting and they
keep through the press keep saying he's
lashing out none of these people in the
press I've ever had a boss because
bosses do this sort of thing all the
time they snap they yell and then five
minutes later they forget it's like it's
like moving to Seattle and waking up
every morning and being surprised that
it's or shock that it's raining that's
the media after year and Avila Trump
every morning they wake up and they're
shocked sharks have balls like that oh
my god they're the best bosses in the
world the bosses that could come in and
shout oh man I just pray for the